we've got the decision now at 3.5
percent
that is exactly in line with the market
expectations I mean if we've been having
this conversation three weeks ago people
were looking for potentially uh a
three-quarter Point hike of the kind
that we got last time around 3.75 but uh
three and a half percent that takes us
back to uh where we were 14 years ago
it's the highest uh level of bank rate
uh for 14 years as I say it's kind of
where the market has been looking over
uh over recent weeks I'm just going to
see if I can try and get some of the uh
data up right now from the the key thing
to look for here is the uh the vote how
the monetary policy committee voted
um that I'm looking at the commentary
here Jane they're saying more Rises to
come so it was a 6-3 vote from the
monetary policy committee to raise to uh
three and a half percent obviously there
are a couple of doves on the MPC
um looking at the statement here it says
the bank of England does not repeat the
November statement that rates unlikely
to reach Peak employed by the markets
that's quite significant basically last
time around when the monetary policy
committee as I say raised from Two and a
quarter percent to three percent there
was a commentary there that uh they said
Market expectations for the future
direction of uh interest rates had been
overdone they haven't said that this
time around which is very interesting
now as I said to you before we got this
decision Jane expectations have been
moderating in recent weeks as to where
the terminal rate where the peak bank
rate will be in this cycle and so maybe
the bank feels that their job is done
for the time being I'm trying to find
out the breakdown here of the vote which
is uh pretty critical
um I've got the the NPC members at
tenniero and ringa voted to keep rated
three percent man voted for 3.75 so that
that gives you the three that voted for
the uh for what is not three you know
3.5 well that's very interesting because
uh the point there is that the two who
want to to keep interest rates where
there were those are the doves that I
was referring to Catherine Mann at the
other end of the spectrum she was she's
seen us very much the more hawkish end
of the monetary policy committee and uh
what is quite surprising actually is
that she's the only member that voted
for a three-quarter Point Raise uh today
because uh several of her colleagues on
the MPC including sir Dave ramsden who
of course is a former treasury official
he uh was seen as being quite hawkish as
well there are one or two of the others
that voted for three quarters last time
that we thought might go again today
that's actually a pretty straightforward
uh vote six six three in that respect so
though it's effectively a three-way
split because you've got two people
there who didn't want interest rates to
rise at all uh one per member who wanted
a three-quarter Point rise rise and the
other six going for half of one percent
I think you could have made a case for
them going uh more aggressively than
that given the extent to which inflation
has uh is still pretty much in the
system I think what may have tipped it
Jane we got the core inflation numbers
yesterday and I call inflation is the
measure of inflation that strips out
volatile elements such as Energy prices
food and drink and tobacco and on that
measurement inflation actually came down
in November from six and a half percent
to uh sorry from 6.5 percent
to 6.3 percent that was lower than
expected and uh that is uh something
that the bank of England would have been
very pleased to see because uh it
suggests that the externally generated
inflation that we've been getting around
the world's largest result of the uh the
war in Ukraine uh that is not feeding
through necessarily to internally uh
generated
um inflation I'm looking at the
statement now from the monetary policy
committee other uh things are on their
mind there there's a commentary here on
the labor market they're saying that
though labor demand has begun to ease
the labor market remains very tight
they're pointing to the fact that
unemployment Rose very slightly to 3.7
percent in the three months to October
vacancies have fallen back so again that
that is something that the MPC is
concerned about
um I'm looking at the uh the bottom line
here it says the majority of the
committee judges that should the economy
evolve broadly in line with the November
monetary policy report projections
further increases in back rate may be
required for a sustainable rate of
return of inflation to Target so that is
a very very clear warning from the
monetary policy committee that further
interest rate Rises are likely as we
were discussing a moment or two ago
okay Ian thanks very much for that for
now